So we just asked you what your favorite application
is. So, Isabelle, let me ask you. What is yours?
>> My favorite application would have to be Google Now.
>> That's a good choice because I just so, it just so happens I have a
screen shot of it right here. So what do you like about it? What is it?
>> Well, I really love Google Now. It's basically an application that
combines all these different data sources or signals about me and kind of
anticipates the information that I might need. First of all, the visual
design is really amazing. I think they really got that right. If you
look at the agency meeting card they just took a lot of information, and put
it in a nice, glanceable way. And it's just really clean and easy to see.
>> Cool.
>> I really like the engineering aspect of
this. So they took so many data sources and
put them into one card. And they, and
the information is really accurate. Another thing that I
really like is the interaction design. Really in
two ways when I first started using Google Now
I didn't have to fill out a lot of
forms or tell a ton of information about myself
to get it set up, it just started kind of learning
from the way I used it. And also the calls to
action or, or the contentional actions off the cars are really
awesome. There's just a few of them and they're really useful.
>> That's awesome, so how would this have gone wrong for you? Like, for
example, in the user interface or engineering
interaction, can, can you give me examples.
>> Yeah.
>> of what happens if you get UI wrong, for example?
>> If you were to get the UI
wrong, the cards would no longer be glanceable. Basically,
you have to stop and really study and read them. They
would no longer be easy to glance at and get information from.
>> Oh, so if I'm on the go, which is the whole
point of this app, that would pretty much make it useless for me.
>> Yeah. Right. So what if they got the engineering wrong?
>> If they got the engineering wrong, basically it would kind of erode your
trust in the application. Like if it told me that my flight was at a
certain time tomorrow, it really wasn't then, or if that wasn't even my terminal
or gate number. You would kind of never
trust the app, and probably stop using it.
>> That's true.
Or if it gave you walking directions to work, that would be really awful.
>> Yeah, that'd be a very long walk. What about this
interaction design thing you talked about? What if they got that wrong?
>> I think it's really crucial how the setup
of Google Now works. It just starts presenting cards
based on your usage, and asking you whether or
not that's useful information for you. So if it had
asked me to fill out, you know, ten pages
of forms, like, like when you're going to a new
doctor's appointment and tell it everything about me I
would have never set it up in the first place.
>> That's true. So it sounds like design is everyone's responsibility.
>> Yeah.
>> And if everyone does their
job, in UI engineering, interaction assignments, and
so on, then the user ends up having an awesome experience with their app.
>> Yup.
>> So let me ask you this again. Like, whose responsibility is design?